Добрий день шановні учасники нашої
презентації Добрий день учасники в
студії Добрий день всім тим хто поза
екраном тих хто взум і тих хто дивляться
нас в онлайн трансляції на YouTube Мене
звати Ірина Шумик і я сьогодні
модеруватиму нашу презентацію цифрової
платформи світ професій і дозвольте
представити наших головних спікерів і
учасників презентації в студії Сергій
шкарлет Міністр освіти і науки України
Юлія Гришина народний депутат України
Василь Кремень президент Національної
академії педагогічних наук України і пан
Олексій Мирошниченко президент інституту
професійних кваліфікацій
шановні друзі ми сьогодні маємо
унікальну наготу ознайомитися з тим чим
саме зараз Міністерство опікується з
питань цифровізації професійної освіти
як змінюється наші реєстри а також
ознайомилися знайомому ознайомимося з
тим а наскільки ми просунулися в
розроблені окремих освітніх ресурсів для
системи професійної освіти звичайно Всі
ми знаємо наскільки сьогодні важливо
забезпечити рівний доступ для всіх
учасників освітнього процесу і для
професійної освіти - це надзвичайний
виклик тому що професійні навички
потрібно здобувати безпосередньо на
виробництві безпосередньо в лабораторії
Але для того щоб Кожен учень І кожен
здобувач професійної освіти отримав
дійсно якісні знання уміння і навичок ми
в Міністерстві освіти і науки а також
наші партнери докладаємо багато зусиль і
працюємо над тим щоб забезпечити і
різними обладнанням і різними
навчальними матеріалами Сьогодні ми
привідкриваємо завісу і презентуємо наші
останні напрацювання і Дозвольте мені
передати зараз слово міністру освіти і
науки пан Сергію шкаррлику про що Сергій
Миколайович Дуже дякую Ірино Шановні
колеги Шановні українці
ви знаєте Ну перш за все 6 грудня день
Збройних Сил України Щиро дякую
нашим воїнам за ту можливість яку ми
маємо сьогодні мати таку презентацію
опікуватися освітнім процесом Нагадую що
ми на 10 день повномасштабного
вторгнення завдячуючи і збройним силам і
колегам нашим освітянам народним
депутатам ми ми відновили освітній
процес і з тих пір він жодного дня не
переривався
попри війну ми сьогодні маємо акценти на
професійні професійні технічній освіті
але при цьому в презентації мого колеги
п Олексія Мирошниченко і того продукту
який створило і Міністерство і презентує
сьогодні інститут професійної
кваліфікації Я дуже багато дотичного в
тому що
ми розвиваємо на базі професійних
кваліфікацій ми розвиваємо і інститут і
зміст вищої освіти з чого все почалося
почалося все з того що ми формували
можливість держави видавати державне
замовлення але давати його цільовим
порядком лише і робити як це на тих хто
готує людей з такими кваліфікаціями які
потім працюють за своїм фахом це було
основне як же це було зробити
голова під комітету з питань вищої
освіти комітету освіти і науки та
інновації пані Юлія Гришина тоді багато
зусиль доклала для того щоб ми все ж
таки цілий рік боролися і ці через рік
ми створили координацію і комунікацію
двох державних реєстрів Реєстр і база
пенсійного фонду і реєстр єдина державна
база з питань освіти на базі цього ми
сьогодні маємо декілька інструментів які
дозволяють здійснювати управлі функції
менеджерські функції розподільчі функції
фінансування в цілому по державі в такій
великій сфері В самій великій сфері
держави як як сфера освіти Ми на
сьогодні в сфері освіти маємо 35 тисяч
закладів якщо взяти в цілому про
будем стартувати з світу професій з
презентації з презентації саме закладів
професійно-технічної і професійної
освіти
з гордістю мушу мушу зазначити що
завершуємо семестр перший семестр 22
навчального року понад 85 закладів
професійної професійно-технічної освіти
працює Приблизно 50 на 50 змішаний або
очний формат е-е дуже маленька кількість
працює дистанційно і ми в 2022 році
прийняли до навчання 225 000 учнів з них
82 000 - Це новий набір основне завдання
яке Ми ставили перед собою це
забезпечити підготовку
фахівця найвищої кваліфікації який би
був потім тим самим драйвером змін і
відновлення України після воєнний час
передбачали декілька змін до
законодавства і
передбачили повторне безоплатне навчання
яке дало можливість сьогодні нам в тому
числі і ветеранам в тому числі і особам
закінчивши військовою кар'єру зробити
новий крок в своєму житті ми сьогодні
перейшли в акцентах щодо зміни категорії
освіта на все життя накид до категорії
освіта впродовж життя і саме цими
змінами в законодавстві ми забезпечуємо
поступовий рух до професії своєї мрії в
залежності від зміни кон'юнктури ринку
праці отже
Основним інструментом сьогодні швидких
перемог є інструмент цифровізації який
дає нам миттєві управлінські рішення
замість стосів талмудів переривання і
добутку кількості інформації адже є
відомий вислів Хто володіє інформацією
тут володіє світом саме його ми взяли на
озброєння Отже
цифрові рішення і цифровізації прошу
перший слайд
в основі цифрової трансформації Ми
поставили два запитання Що ми робимо
яким чином звісно підвищуємо цих
ворогами це сучасники освітнього процесу
звісно автоматизуємо процеси звісно
покращуємо диякості до до освіти і
Найбільше це
2,2 джерела співпраця з донорами і
державне приватне партнерство і саме
Сьогодні ми демонструємо яким чином
співпраця з донорами і державне приватне
партнерство формує успіх в нашій справі
Отже підвищення цифрової грамотності
бачимо
понад тисячу педагогів пройшли 128
тренінгів 27 навчальних
навчально-методичних центрів та 59
профтехів пройшли навчання за ліцензію
за безкоштовного ліцензію донорської
підтримкою Microsoft Office 365
селайф один з онлайних інструментів вже
впроваджено і проведено 45
проведено навчання 45 педагогів закладів
професійний професійно-технічної освіти
щодо створення онлайн-контенту всередині
своїх закладів причому ці 45 педагогів
будуть робити так звані дисимінаtion по
всіх закладах професійної освіти
сьогодні триває курс триває розробку
курсу цифрової безпеки Я сподіваюсь що
за два тижні ми можемо презентувати вже
нову платформу
що стосується автоматизації процесів це
і завершення розроблення
спеціалізованого модуля в нашій системі
так званій icom і Юлія Миколаївна якраз
була тим драйвером коли ця система Icon
в залі парламенту була підтримана і ми
сьогодні маємо платформу для здійснення
цифровізації цифрових інструментів
розроблено і впроваджено її є кабінет
вступника по закладу закладам профтехоти
і саме в цьому році ми вже мали
можливість його апробувати разом з
нашими партнерами європейським надійним
надійною програмою і у форс Skills і в
найближчому майбутньому електронний
журнал інтегрований В той самий iPhone в
імс оперативного обліку
далі
доступності освіти
платформа професійна освіта онлайн на
сьогодні через два тижні ми теж її
будемо презентувати як один з
інструментів доступу до освіти з один з
інструментів генерації
уроку
працевлаштування уроку
висвітлення тих комерційних переваг з
одної чи з іншої професії
грамотності щодо майбутнього вступу і
застосування себе як фахівця Тобто це
урок професійної
профорієнтації які ми запровадили вже в
системі освіти вже другий рік поспіль
покращення доступності також це ми
сьогодні покриваємо 36 онлайн курсів за
професіями разом з нашими донорами і у
скворскіз і ло і ФС і
TF і ці всі уроки
на Сумщині але це є лише перший крок
покращення доступності
забезпечення обладнанням 20
інтерактивних навчальних панелей за
сурфіз Hub це наші колеги які нас
підтримали і також дозволяють нам
рухатись в напрямку в напрямку підтримки
представників
професійно-технічної освіти наш вагомий
партнер знову ж таки і уфер Skills це 27
it-лабораторій Це більше ніж 5 000
ноутбуків за рахунок наших колег із
юнісеф 50 тисяч хромбуків це Google і
Юнеско причому це тільки в цьому році
Я дуже дякую нашим партнерам компанії
Google Microsoft Zoom в Європейському
Союзу інституту професійних кваліфікації
це якраз та зовнішня підтримка донорська
Але яка перетікає в якість цифрової
освіти і в якість взагалі професійної
освіти сьогодні на території
Але ж я хотів би сьогодні окрім
державного донорського партнерства
презентувати хоча перші е-е перші перші
слова сказати слова вдячності інституту
професійної кваліфікації директор
інституту професійних кваліфікації пану
усім Мирошниченко який одразу ж після
того був також в контексті розробки
законопроектів і
нормативних документів щодо зведення
реєстрів пенсійного фонду і
єдиний державний бази з питань освіти і
сьогодні ми маємо дуже яскраву і цікаву
цифрову платформу яка дає нам можливість
миттєво приймати рішення щодо
профорієнтації щодо свідомого вибору
професії щодо успішного професійного
навчання та кар'єрного зростання тут
зібраний декілька цифрових інструментів
які дозволяють нам чітко виокремити
перелік професій за якими ми хочемо
кудись вступати чітко виокремити перелік
закладів які дає можливість
набути цю професію чітко виокремити
професійну програму всередині цієї
професії яка дозволяє потім визнати свою
професійну кваліфікацію Окрім цього
сьогодні ведеться робота знаком
національним агентством кваліфікації
Щодо можливості гармонізації набутих
професійних навичок з рамкою
кваліфікації Європейського Союзу це теж
дуже цінно
ми сьогодні маємо можливість її
використовувати програмплатформу світ
професій не тільки в частині презентації
певних здобутків певних закладів освіти
пошуку профорієнтації пошуку професії
пошуку закладу ми ще ще і певним чином
зачіпаємо тут і заклади вищої освіти які
дає нам можливість виокремити саме
відсоток працевлаштування тобто не
тільки профосвіта а ще й заклади вищої
освіти задіяні в цьому контексті і ми
маємо можливість оцінити ефективність
використання
коштів виділених державою або або
приватною особою або або тим самим
здобувачем освіти коштів які він
витратив на свою освіту і потім її
цільове цюльове
цільову ефективність адже коли ми коли
ми з вами чітко розуміємо що ми готували
інженера авіоніка а він з авіоніки а він
потім працює
продавцем в магазині всі професії
важливі всі всі вони потрібні на
сьогодні але чи варто було б витрачати
кошти на підготовку саме до фахівця який
за такою складною професією не йшов вже
знайшов працювати по своєму напрямку в
цифровій платформі професійної освіти
світ професій Ми сьогодні чітко чітко
після того як ми її запустили ми чітко
побачили дуже вразливі і важливі цифри
наприклад ліцензованих професій
662 з них професії підготовки лише 302
за якими здійснюється сьогодні
підготовка закладами освіти адже нашу
нам тоді всі інші 350 більше ніж 350
Вони мають ознаку застарілості Вони
мають вони тільки в оману вводять при
наприклад при
професійному налаштуванні студента або
абітурієнта на той чи інший заклад ми
сьогодні маємо державні стандарти
професійної освіти лише з 356 професії з
яких ліцензовано дійсно
62 ми сьогодні маємо
кваліфікаційні характеристики лише по
476 професій ми сьогодні маємо
професійні стандарти яких лише 109 і оце
напрямок руху який дається платформа яка
дає можливість навіть абітурієнту
оцінити чи є професійний стандарт по тій
чи іншій професії який заявляє заклад чи
заклад спроможний надати повну
компетентність вивченні курсу чи
ліцензовані ліцензовані Ці професії в
тому чи іншому закладі
Саме основне ми можемо звернутись до
літератури ми можемо звернутись там дуже
цікава аналітика Я б хотів би потім щоб
пан Олексій показав саме
графу аналітика і розкрив її показавши
саме
елементи відсоток працевлаштування
закладів випускників закладів вищої
освіти які чітко покаже мапу України за
Тіми закладами освіти які спроможні
сьогодні
підготувати фахівця саме за тією
професією яку він обрав і ви знаєте як
би підготовка оцих всіх
цифрових рішень на сьогодні дозволяє нам
з вами мати чіткий управлінський
цифровий управлінський інструмент Який
дасть можливість миттєво виокремити
відповідь на то чи інше професійне
запитання Я вам дуже дякую
Сергію Миколайовичу і Дозвольте шановні
учасники нашої трансляції надати слово
зараз пані Юлії гришині народними
депутатами України пані Юлія
Дякую
Вітаю всіх колег я вітаю всіх тих хто
дивиться нас сьогодні не можу не
привітати
всіх всю нашу країну з Днем збройних сил
України і подякувати нашим збройним
силам за те що ми боремося за те що ми
живемо працюємо робимо те що ми сьогодні
про що ми сьогодні говоримо і
система освіти працює
ви знаєте я хочу сказати що ми сьогодні
презентуємо цифрову платформу освіти
професії я ось повернулася нещодавно з
Польщі де ми презентували з нашими
ректорами технічних наших університетів
велику програму таку схожу цифрову
платформу по підтримці наших жінок які
більше мільйони яких знаходяться у
Польщі для того щоб навчати їх цифровій
надавати їм цифри і навички і потім
працевлаштовувати їх і коли в Польщі
виступав міністр правової трансформації
він ще раз сказав про те що Україна є
таким загальносвітовим прикладом е-е
таких величезних успіхів у цифровій
трансформації що ми до війни зробили
такий рух вперед який не зробила жодна
країна в світі і ще раз говорили про те
що нас застосунок дія є найкращим в
світі і жодна країна світу не може до
сих пір повторити
говорити аналогічну платформу і навіть
така країна як Естонія яка ми знаємо Це
маленька Країна в якій проживає трохи
більше мільйона громадян і вона повністю
є цифровізованою а вони досить пір не
можуть створити подібний і застосунок як
Наша дія тому наша країна в сфері
цифрової трансформації діджиталізації є
світовим лідером і звичайно система
освіти не повинна відставати і не
відстає що стосується цифрового
інноваційного розвитку і Я сьогодні хочу
подякувати безпосередньо всім тим хто
дотичний до сьогоднішнього Заходу Я хочу
подякувати Сергій Миколайовичу скарлику
за велику пророблену роботу тому що це
дійсно велика і складна і надважлива
робота і головне що вона закінчиться
таким результатом який ми сьогодні для
вас всіх презентуємо я хочу подякувати
всім колегам які тут присутні які теж
долучилися до створення ось того
продукту які ми сьогодні маємо І це ще
одна гордість чим ми можемо пишатися в
сфері цифрової трансформації оскільки
цифровізація освітніх процесів для нас є
надважливою нас є досвід ковіду коли ми
два роки працювали на дистанції ми
справилися і теж велика кількість країн
світу не змогла показати такі результати
як показала українська система освіти і
зараз в умовах війни Коли в нас виклики
набагато складніші все одно ми боремося
ми працюємо і велика роль в цьому грає
безпосередньо звичайно система
цифровізації освітніх процесів тому ми з
вами на правильному шляху
працюємо далі щоб оскільки
війна скоро закінчиться нашою перемогою
ми будемо відбудовувати нову інноваційну
цифрову країну продовжувати її
відбудовувати і нам Звичайно
потрібно буде тримати рівень найкращої
країни в світі по
цифровізації і в тому числі освітніх
процесів Дякую колеги Всіх вітаю дякую
пані Юлія дозволяю собі продовжити
власне думку А коли ми дійсно можемо
подивитися на те що якісь професії
сьогодні стають застарілими або не є
актуальними на ринку праці варто також
звертати увагу А що ж сьогодні чого
сьогодні потребує роботодавець і власне
дійсно сфера IT для України може бути
таким дивом яке в подальшому допоможе
відбудувати нашу державу і досягти
потужного економічного розвитку Але для
цього для цього потрібні відповідні
лабораторії для цього потрібні навчені
викладачі звичайно стандарти програми і
професії і ми дійсно теж працюємо над
тим щоби нові цифрові професії у сфері
професійної освіти якомога швидше
з'явилася І власне для всього цього
потрібно більш детальні навички так або
як ми це говоримо цифрові навички
переглядаючи наші стандарти А ми щороку
затверджуємо оновлюємо понад 30
стандартів а сьогодні цифрова
компетентність є однією із ключових І
власне це можна набути обов'язково через
практику А для цього повинні бути і
відповідні цифрові ресурси ще краще коли
таких ресурсів є багато і кожна особа
Кожен громадянин має відповідний вибір
користуватися тими ресурсами які для
нього є цікавіші зручніше або які він
вважає більш якісними І тому ми
надзвичайно раді що сьогодні презентують
платформу наш давні партнери з якими
реалізовано не один проект з якими ми
багато працювали на дослідженнями ринку
праці а сьогодні Починаємо працювати у
сфері створення електронних навчальних
матеріалів власне це інститут
професійних кваліфікацій і я з радістю
передаю слово для подальшої презентації
для того щоб поділитися батьками всіма
можливостями нової цифрової платформи
світ професій президенту інституту
професійних кваліфікацій пане Олексію
Мирошниченко п Олексію вам слово дякую
пані Ірина Добрий день шановні колеги
міністр Шановні колеги я хочу теж
приєднатися до привітання нашим збройним
силам більш того сказати що один із
членів нашої команди який приймав
активну участь у розробці цієї платформи
зараз на східному фронті на самій
гарячці точці Я думаю що він Якщо буде
можливість подивитися і розповів своїм
колегам про нашу спільну роботу
ідея в нас виникла
буквально рік тому рік тому е-е
буквально на початку війни Коли ми
почули скільки не знищено закладів
професійної освіти оскільки
завдано шкоди системі освіти і ми
вирішили якимось чином допомогти це
перший чинник другий чинник те що
говорив Сергій Миколайович те що дійсно
відбулися
і пенсійним фондом дуже довго цей про це
йшов але ми вдячні міністерстві міністру
що він завершився Ну і звичайно треба
подякувати уряду президенту України коли
була створена рада з Профі розвитку
професійної освіти і ми отримали певний
поштовх для нашої роботи
будь ласка е-е перший слайд Сергій
Миколайович уже говорив про
ту ситуацію яка зараз є забезпеченням і
професійними стандартами
полі-характеристиками
державними стандартами професійної
освіти Ми коли подивились на цю картину
Ми вирішили глибше подивитися ми глибше
ми подивилися скільки навчальних програм
скільки підручників і під час роботи Ми
пройшли е-е про моніторили всі без
виключення сайти професійно-технічних
закладів всі без виключення Ми також
подивились всі НАУ медичні центри
подивились і ми спробували відкритому
доступі Зібрати всі матеріали для
розміщення на одній площадке яка була
ідеологія ми взяли за основу
класифікатор професій ми взяли будь
ласка якщо можна наступний слайд я потім
повернусь до класифікатора була як ідея
яка Ну по-перше профорієнтація пан
міністр про все вже говорив для
старшокласників це і для їх батьків
свідомий вибір професії що вони бачили
що йому треба буде вивчити де він може
працювати яку він зарплату може отримати
тобто яка його Кар'єрна зростання може
бути
під час своє трудової діяльності
дорослим багато міняють людей професію
особливо ну в середньому людина раз на
сім років міняє сферу своєї активності
трудової і я думаю це теж допоможе
безробітнім Ну і саме головне викладачам
викладачів ми зробили особливий акцент
щоб вони могли
у розрізі професії ознайомити з усіма
без виключення навчальними матеріалами
які є відкритому доступі от все що може
бути підручники навчальні програми
авторські відеокурси відео курси та
курси додана віртуальної реальності ну і
багато чого іншого будь ласка наступний
слайд от структура за основу взяти
Робітнича професія штукатур як приклад
далі ми там перейдем до
іншої професії іде короткий на сторінці
йде короткий опис професії і де
презентаційне відео там де вони є і ми
вдячні Міністерство освіти за те що вже
з'являються профорієнтаційні ролики і
відеоролики якими теж розміщуємо далі
йде
повністю аналітика може бути по всій
професії нормативні документи підручники
тести таке інше інше інше Ну і навчальні
дисципліни і предмети будь ласка
наступний слайд
отак виглядає Наша перша сторінка
платформи от ми бачимо іде опис про те
що я вже сказав потім ідуть професію
такий слайдери де
в кінці сторінки Як що треба щоб стати
учнем професійно-технічного закладу те
що можна зробив для дорослих і які треба
документи представити все все працює в
режимі онлайн можна досить легко
подивитися наступне будь ласка
далі от ми взяли професію
електрогазозварювальник ви бачите коди
7212 Це вона повністю відповідає
класифікатору і де повністю опис
професії і де Ну фотографія Ну і де
відеоролік профорієнтаційний який і
дисципліни за профільним які має бути
внизу дві таких невеличкі віконце
навчальні заклади і навчальні матеріали
будь ласка наступний склад
навчальний заклад де є інтерактивна мапа
України коли ви натискаєте на любу
область нашої держави внизу буде
Практично всі будуть всі навчальні
заклади які надають цю чи цю професію по
цьому коду це даний є деба або Можна
вручну ввести або оберіть за списком
Тобто ви набираєте штукатур чим маляр чи
любу професію і зразу ви побачите
Де можна здобути цю професію будь ласка
наступний слайд
коли ви коли ви тиснете на навчальний
матеріал перед вами відкриваються поки
що шість віконцев 6 віконців - це
підручники От бачите ми загрузили по
газозварювальних як всі підручники якими
знайшли відкритому доступі вони
відкриваються можна ознайомитись таке
інше також будуть будь ласка наступний
слайд також буде аут це підручник як він
відкривається його можна подивитися
використовувати будь ласка ще один слайд
да далі будуть у нас навчальні матеріали
от є стандарти професійної освіти є
поліферистика і є уже і професійний
стандарт є і Зараз будуть будь ласка
наступний буде відео
[музика]
до власне безпосередньо щоб ми ще раз
будь ласка наступний слайд радіо
бачите також є відеоматеріали є
профорієнтаційно відео а також є вже
відео по технологічному процесу які
можна теж е-е використовувати оце
приблизно така структура і так це
зроблено по всім 300 е-е буде зроблено
по всім 300 двом професіям Ми зараз в
стадії наповнення цієї платформи і ми
просили Сергій Миколайович і вас
допомогти нам ну таку знаєте зробити
толоку свого роду щоб ми наповнили цими
матеріалами як якими є тут була прохання
і до Василь Григорович Шевченко академія
підключилися і всі наші освітяни які на
зараз слухають Це перша частина тепер
друга частина Про яку говорив Сергій
Миколайович Я думаю або ми переходимо до
онлайн може до онлайн перейдемо
те що ми можемо зараз включити власне
безпосередньо і Шановні колеги друзі
подивитися як працює платформа або
безпосередньо в режимі онлайн Наш колега
показує всі куди можна переходити
заходити Я дуже прошу тих хто в нас
сьогодні працює з нами в Зумі а або
працює в онлайн трансляції переглядає
нас онлайн трансляція ви можете зараз
задавати свої питання або залишати
коментарі я їх з радістю озвучу нашим
доповідачам і ми зможемо ще додатково за
потреби розширити всю інформацію в нас
демонструється наразі сама платформа
ресурс і пане Олексію Продовжуйте тоді
коментувати Дякую пане Ірина пані Ірино
ви бачите отут нас розміщено в режимі
підвіконції аналітика розміщені декілька
дашбордів всього є даж бордів 43 43 Якщо
ви будете
користуватись цим ви побачите тут дуже
багато різноманітної інформації
але знову-таки звідки все почалося Я теж
Дякую Сергію Миколайовичу за те що ми
два роки тому підписали меморандум про
проведення е-е експерименту пілотного
проекту в Житомирської і по областям і
де ми хотіли дати то що говорив пан
міністр
реальний інструмент як приймати
управлінське рішення на основі чого
приймаються управлінські рішення ми
подивились вакансії ми подивились
працевлаштування Ми багато ещё
подивились і ви щось такими рекомендації
і все дало нам можливість
зробити от 43 по-моєму дажби які в себе
включають по-перше повний аналіз системи
професійної освіти наявність навчальних
закладів в вакансії заробітної плати
таке інше інше інше да регіональне
замовлення да відповідність ринку праці
і невідповідність ринку праці що до речі
теж в очі більш того там даже є
працевлаштування наших людей за кордоном
є мапа куди наше
працевлаштовується але тільки що я
наголошую це офіційні дані бо ми
використовуємо в своїй роботі тільки
офіційні дані Все йде бо Пенсійний фонд
Державна служба зайнятості статистика
наша і реєстр юридичних і фізичних осіб
тому що це дуже важливо при
працевлаштуванні коли фопи щоб ми теж
побачили також от ви бачите зараз слайд
про який вірніше дажборт про який
обговорював Сергій Миколайович все про
все влаштування випускників закладів
освіти
Ми це зробили за три роки за три роки Ні
я сейчас розкажу все вся без виключена
більш того не професійна освіта вища
освіта і в розрізі регіонів навчальних
закладів спеціальностей спеціальностей і
за бюджет чи за власні кошти вчилися
Тобто ми можемо показати загальну
картину на протязі трьох років
користуючись нагодою Сергій Миколайович
до вас прохання у нас не було обміну
даними за 21 і за 22-й рік аби ви
ініціювали щоб Пенсійний фонд і є де би
ініціювали ми можемо мали картину за 5
років оці п'ять
і ми були вам би вдячні да юліям
Миколаївна Сергію Миколайович ми були
вам дуже вдячні ми побачили картину на
протязі 5 років
абсолютно Да і ми могли вам покласти да
більш того аби ми поєднали зусилля ще з
академією педагогічних наук і по
оптимізації навчальних закладів Це все
було б дійсно аби вже приймали
серйознулась приймали управлінські
рішення Що з цим робити або так Або так
Або так тобто оце всі
механізми є далі йде от вступ по кожній
професії по кожній навчальному закладу
оскільки є ліцензійні умови і скільки
факт про що говорив міністр потрібно чи
не потрібно але знову-таки це нам
вирішувати практично в режимі онлайн
йдуть і йдеться інформація там по кожний
дашборт можна дальше далі-далі бо це
тільки перший Ну бачите Сім сторінок на
цьому дажбоді наступний коли ми побачимо
там буде Да Поточний стан ринку праці он
бачите дані Практично на
5.12 да змінилася щось у пенсійному
фонді в умовно кажучи з'явилась у нас
дані що
державних служб зайнятості
ідеактуалізації йдуть по зарплаті ідуть
по вакансії Ну от все повністю є вся
тобто по великому рахунку при бажанні
управлінці управлінці можуть приймати да
от є рейтинг найбільш затребуваних
професій і таке інше інше але знову
наголошую що це не до речі мабуть перші
хто зробили неформально з неформально
зайнятості Да тут
інституту імені птухи
більш того і тут я хотів би Да хотів би
абсолютно я вам щиро вдячну А це до речі
цікавий слайд про все влаштування наших
людей за кордоном За кордоном але це
тільки це офіційні дані і хай вас не
дивує Кіпр Кіпр
4247 саморяки ми подивились звідки з цим
моряки але все офіційні дані які
пресилаштовані через наші агентства
зайнятості які надали звітність от іде
повністю але всього-на-всього 24 це теж
цікава інформація для для роздуму а
користуючись нагодою хотів би подякувати
елементу і яка яка підтримується наш
проект більш того у них на сайті
розмічана обсерваторія ринку праця наш
продукт і ми дуже активно співпрацюємо і
не думаю що і далі будемо працювати оце
Практично все що ми хотіли сьогодні
показати але є
прохання Сергій Миколайович ми давали
вам пропозиції щоб ми разом більше
активізували роботу над наповненням
платформи це разом із Ми б хотіли
попрацювати і цю там освітній аналітики
особливо були вдячні за більш чисну
співпрацю з едебо з якими працюємо тобто
все що є інструменти які є в
міністерстві були вдячні за спільну
роботу Ну і Аналогічно користуючись
нагодою хочу звернутися до всіх закладів
навчальних закладів Колеги давайте разом
Бо одна із проблем яку ми подивились це
е наповнення навчальними матеріалами е-е
навчального процесу Вибачте за
тавтологію Ми повинні мотивувати
викладачів викладачів писати робити
авторські курси писати підручники
можливо даже мотивувати Сергій
Михайлович ми про це говорили економічно
це дуже серйозна робота написати
авторський курс по професії по
технології
підручник він займає багато часу Я думаю
що якщо ми знайдемо механізм ідеї в нас
є як підтримати авторів на платформі то
ми дійсно зробили такий е-е спільний
продукт і ви правильно сказали все
дійсно реальне державне приватне
партнерство бізнесу освітян Ну і
сподіваюсь Верховної Ради Да дякую
Шановні колеги якщо будуть запитання
задоволенням відповім
всі наші глядачі Нагадую що ви можете
залишати ваші запитання у коментарях під
трансляцією або тих хто в нас працюють в
Зумі можете писати в Zoom А я
надзвичайно радо Вітаю тих хто зміг вже
доєднатися у кого щойно з'явилося світле
і вони долучилися до нас загалом нас
переглядає більше ніж 300 учасників
наразі і ми вже розмістили посилання на
платформу назву платформи і після
завершення трансляції Ми з разом з усіма
матеріалами з усіма презентації теж
зробимо відповідну публікацію А зараз
вашого дозволу Я би хотіла передати
слово
президенту Національної академії
педагогічних наук України п Василю
кременю власне Василь Григорович Тут
таке питання ми розуміємо наскільки
багато зараз і викладачі національної
академія педагогічних наук працюють над
тим щоб оновити зміст освіти і
професійної освіти в тому числі і власне
ми щиро особливими інституту
професійно-технічної освіти який активно
З нами працює над розробленням цифрових
матеріалів ваша думка Я знаю що ви вже
знайомі з платформою Як ви вважаєте де і
як нам би було і краще використовувати
Дякую пане Ірина
шановні сторінка
Юрій Миколаївна Олексій Валентинович
Шановні колеги я хотів би всіляко
підтримати проект світ професій про який
зараз говорив Олексій Валентинович він
абсолютно в контексті політики
Міністерства освіти науки яка
проводиться в останні роки щодо і
розвитку професійної
професійно-технічної освіти і
цифровізації і інших напрямків Я взагалі
хочу сказати що безумовно аналіз того як
розвивалась в якому стані Як працювала
освіта в Україні під час війни буде
зроблено пізніше після війни але вже
зараз може сказати що Міністерство
освіти і науки за підтримки Комітет
Верховної Ради інших колег зробили
надзвичайно багато що був в умовах війни
закінчити успішну навчальний рік
провести знову ж таки успішно вступну
кампанію До
закладів освіти розпочати навчальний рік
і ось за умови того що
значна частина закладів і дітей
знаходяться на тимчасово окупованій
території все-таки залучити всі бажаючі
до навчання в різних
закладах і професійної вищої освіти тому
Сергій Миколайович Я думаю що
історія віддасть належне всім діючим
особам в цьому відношенні щодо проекту я
окрім
такої загальної позитивної оцінки А я
мав можливість познайомити познайомитись
уже з цим проектом я хотів передати і
заключення наших фахівців зокрема з
інститут професійної освіти про
надзвичайно високу оцінку необхідність
потребу в ньому і готовність наших
вчених зокрема з інституту професійної
освіти активно долучитись до наповнення
цього
проекту
знову ж таки не буде переказувати його
можливості
скажу лише що подібної платформи в
Україні в сфері освіти а можливо не
тільки сфери освіти не було і немає і
тому Сергій Миколайовичу те що з боку
Міністерства така активна підтримка і
зацікавленість в реалізації це це
Та це дійсно це Партнерство і державного
приватної Партнерство освітяни і
роботодавців е-е підприємців
хоча безумовно є питання які потрібно
допрацювання врахувати наприклад наші
колеги вважають що було бажано визначити
механізм комунікації представників
закладів освіти і за інтерпресованих
сторін за адміністратором платформи
приєднання до платформи та розміщення
матеріалів або скажімо
щодо швидкого переходу на сторінку
професії бажано створити головну меню
відповідну вкладку виникає
ряд питань щодо представлення на
платформі навчальних матеріалів зокрема
яким чином будуть відбиратися навчальні
матеріали і питання як регулюватиметься
авторське право розробників навчальних
матеріалів але це всі питання це ті які
умовний робочі абсолютно і обумовлені
так би мовити
розширенням зростанням цього цього
проекту Я хотів би сказати буквально два
слова що Національна академія
педагогічного наук надзвичайно багато
приділяє уваги і
професійній професійно-технічній освіті
е-е ми
могли місця провели місяць і провели все
академічні методичні семінар за участю
роботодавців щодо розвитку
професійно-технічної професійної освіти
в умовах війни нових викликів відповідей
можливих на ці виклики підготували
рекомендації Сергій Миколайович Я вчора
підписав лист на вас і на Комітет
Верховної Ради іншим колегам щодо цих
рекомендацій для можливого використання
щодо цифровізації ми в цьому році
перетворили один з інститутів в інститут
цифровізації і останні наші збори
були присвячені якраз проблеми
цифровізації в освіті України вони
проведені теж ось в листопаді місяці
Сергій Миколайович ми вдячний вам за
участь
сусіданні е-е
президент академії де ми знову ж таки в
листопаді обговорювали підсумки
виконання спільних програм і спільної
діяльності Міністерства освіти науки і
академії який надзвичайно
великі різно
різні аспекти затро- різні проблеми і ми
підсумували зроблено за цей рік От і
Дякуємо за вашу
позитивну оцінку цієї діяльності і ззаді
зауваження побажання які ви зробили ми в
наступному році безумовно Це врахуємо
одним словом я вважаю що це
дуже потрібний проект проект який йде в
руслі от тих досягнень про які говорила
Миколаївна
посилаючись на на Польщу Ми теж
неодноразово з поляками зараз тісно
співпрацюємо зченими з усіма і знаємо їх
теж позитивне ставлення і я думаю що при
загальній підтримці і провідній ролі
Міністерства Щодо його запровадження
цього проекту це буде надзвичайно
корисно для всіх і для тих хто
навчається професійній освіті і той хто
збирається навчатися вибирає професію
тих хто навчає От і тих хто керує цією
системою Дякую за увагу
я бачу у вас є коментар так прошу
буквально коротко Дякую Василю за теплі
слова я буквально декілька слів
коментарів ми були вдячні царю
Миколайовичу і прохання є до вас Ми
планували зробити окремий технічний
презентацію ще для
науково-методичних центрів і і
викладачів навчальних закладів щоб іноді
дійсно поговорити по всій верифікації
про яку ви говорили як розміщувати який
зворотній зв'язок є і таке інше І ще
одне наступний крок який ми плануємо е-е
зробити там з'явиться ще з часом одне
віконце віконце яке буде мати таку назву
знання і навички і ми хочемо кожну
професію подивитися відносно Еска Еска
це дуже велика робота вона Скажем так
має певне і євроінтеграційний характер
тому що ми йдем Європу але повірте мені
робота дуже-дуже складна тому Ще раз
дякую за тепле слова
Дякую пане Олексію А в нас власне наразі
є запитання з Фейсбука Скажіть будь
ласка уточнюють наші колеги адже є
інформація в розрізі недержавних
закладів освіти пане Олексію Я думаю що
це більше запитання до вас от з тих
презентованих матеріалів які були
цифрові
чи є інформація про діяльність
недержавних закладів професійної освіти
Ну звичайно є любий заклад який який є в
єдиній базі здобувачів освіти є Ось все
що є там може бути трошки інший код Ми
там дивилися останні це все є там десь
біля мі колеги підскажуть тут в селі
Олексійович притаманов Скільки в нас там
ми 1 000 з чимось да навчальних закладів
да всіх хто має ліцензію
заклади професійної освіти або
відповідно інші суб'єкти освітньої
діяльності які отримали ліцензію
інформація про них облікові дані вони
наведені на платформі інша інформація
про можливо їх діяльність тут треба
розмовляти далі тому що ми ще навіть
цієї інформації не маємо в нашій системі
icom яка зараз еміс доопрацьовується ми
сподіваємося у 23-му році вже почне свою
роботу шановні друзі Шановні колеги це
було запитання до нас із фейсбуку Наразі
я не бачу інших коментарів і запитань у
нашому Зумі
бачу що до нас доєднуються учасники з
Херсону Херсон Ми нарешті раді що ви
зможете і Зможете і будете продовжувати
працювати з нами
шановні друзі шановні учасники в студії
чи є ще коментарі
так якщо нема коментарів то власне є
побажання я так тому що це побажання
повернутися до роботи і налагоджувати і
далі нашу співпрацю я користуюсь нагодою
теж хочу привітати всіх
військовослужбовців збройних сил України
щиро вам вклоняємося і Дякуємо за те що
ми сьогодні можемо творити майбутнє
шановні друзі Дякую всім що були з нами
до нових зустрічей